then you're going to Barcelona for the
big show what are you looking for well
we're looking for I think privacy
identity and security as a whole is
going to be the big topic this year so
we're looking to not only show we have
but also to stimulate a much broader
discussion against the industry
participants what is it that can be done
to better protect cell phone users and
all of our data that's out there right
now what what measures are you taking
and would you like to be would you like
to see be taking well we're putting
forward a proposal where there's three
things that have to happen tools
transparencies and behaviors and on the
tools we as an industry just need to
make this much much much simpler you
know we surveyed a whole group of people
and what we found was 90% of them said
they're worried about their online
security and privacy but yet less than
twenty percent said they're actually
doing something so we have to make them
aware and when we dug it that a little
bit masked why they're not doing
anything they said it's just too
difficult I don't know what to download
every product looks different there's a
whole bunch of different vendors and so
we are unveiling something that makes it
very very simple security as a service
the second is transparency is an
industry you know when I add up all the
apps i have and the websites that i've
looked at and i download the privacy
scripts and policies it takes me 76 days
to rio that's they really make it easier
way sir yeah and I'm with you and then
the Saudi consumers respond to that go
ahead and then the third thing is
consumers have to take action themselves
less than ten percent download a simple
anti-virus program or any other security
products so there's a lot that can be
done I the consumers are they fully
aware of how much information is
actually collected on them when they're
online no I would say generally speaking
the population still doesn't have the
same anxiety we used to have on a
desktop and so because it comes in much
smaller bites and one person in in third
part of the world another person here in
North America another person in New York
you know we just don't add up to
something that's newsworthy like a hack
of JPMorgan for example